[Applause]
it is almost thanksgiving and do i have
a recipe for you it's a beautiful roast
with stuffing my favorite food and why
we only have it once a year
is not okay with it i guess that makes
me appreciate it more but i could eat
stuffing 365 and i also live for gravy
like a good rich hearty deep brown roux
driven gravy but i have a twist this
one's completely meatless
and you will not even know the
difference
corn is a company that is actually
global
um and it has come here to this country
and i am the new cmo
that's chief mom officer
that's right
and i care about the messaging and the
marketing and the branding and i am
addicted to this product and i believe
in it and now our show is working with
them too and they have a selection of
delicious meat-free products that are
available nationally at whole foods and
in the frozen meatless section at
several other grocery stores around the
country this is very accessible
and
i find it unparalleled in taste
integrity it is something that i'm very
proud to be a part of this company my
kids and i eat it
and so first
this is corn's meatless vegetarian
turkey it is so easy to prepare you just
preheat your oven to 425 degrees and you
place it on parchment paper and you put
on a baking sheet if it's frozen it's
about 55 minutes if it's thawed out it's
about 50. and then we're going to
prepare a mushroom gravy in this pot all
right our heat is on so i have sauteed
down these mushrooms with shallot and a
little olive oil with the butter so the
butter doesn't burn
and do not salt your mushrooms until the
last minute
because it actually leeches the water
out so it completely changes the dynamic
of them so once they're cooked you want
to give them that salt and pepper so
we're going to make a roux
right here and i'm going to put the
flour in
and then i'm just going to mix that
together for about two minutes until it
kind of all
coalesces
and congeals and coats
never met a roux i didn't love
and then the next step you would take
is adding in
your white wine
then i'm going to add
the next step is my stock
oopsy daisy that's right yeah there we
go yeah
i'm not perfect in the kitchen nor do i
ever act like it the new book is called
rebel homemaker for a reason
um
you know if i'm laughing and my hair is
on fire and i'm enjoying myself and i'm
happy that's how it works and looks in
the kitchen at my house all right so i
just added tamari which is so amazing
salty
umami
delicious it also brings a beautiful
color and helps add that richness
to the gravy and then you're just going
to take a little bit of herbs um parsley
sage and thyme and i'm gonna throw it
and i'm gonna bring it down to a simmer
and i'm gonna go for about 10 minutes
and then
um we have a chef that works with corn
the great steven and he had this great
idea to put your stuffing in a waffle
maker and i was like oh yeah oh yeah i
can get into that
so
again i love a classic stuffing and
what pilar brought the idea to this dish
was adding dried cranberries in it and
because this does go in a waffle maker i
did love the idea of the subliminal
sweetness because we think of waffles as
something that we put syrup on and we're
going with a savory gravy so the dried
cranberries give that little pop so now
that we've got all this i'm just going
to show you what an end result will be
i'm moving everything to the side here
is my end result of my gravy
one thing that i really love about this
gravy too it has really large pieces of
mushroom which if you're a vegetarian by
the way your mushroom is your best
friend um so
basically here you go you can do this
you can move your little waffle
and then i'm gonna struggle to get these
on the plate
and see okay yeah
um
but
so
here is my take
on a
uh
see what i did i ran out of gravy oh
well um it's all gonna go in the same
place anyway
um but i'm just so excited to be working
as the new cmo of corn and this is our
first dish that we're making on the show
and it'll be the first of many to any
parents out there or nugget lovers
i've never had nuggets this amazing in
my life there is no soy in this product
it's so wonderful and they have so many
different types of products i am so
proud and excited to bring this
thanksgiving
alternative to you so make sure you go
to the drewberrymore show.com for the
full recipe and for the perfect picky
eaters in your house
try these nuggets we'll be right back
[Music]